العسكرية وفاء للشهيد عدي
التميمي. رجل يضرم النار مطعم
يرد على من وصفهم بانهم يصرخون
ويشتكون من ارتفاع اسعار الطاقة
مشاريع كأس العالم ام ماذا?
الفلسطينيون يلقون التحية
مائتين وخمسين دولارا. ماذا بك
يا هذا? اتريد تعويض تكاليف
مخابرات شديدة الحساسية عن ايران
والصين بحسب واشنطن بوست. ووفق
بيتسبرج بولاية بنسلفينج. رئيس
وزراء الاسبق الشيخ حمد بن جاسم
مستندات شديدة الخطورة ضبطت
بمنزل ترامب تحتوي على معلومات
وامريكا كانوا يعذبون السجناء
حتى وقرار غزو العراق يشبه ما
فعله هتلر وموسوليني بعصبة
الامم. لتظهر السفيرة الامريكية
يا للعجب! لكن اليوم يظهر مقطع
قديم اعيد تداوله لسفير بريطاني
العراق فسادا فعذبوا وقتلوا
واحرقوا ودمروا. لم يتركوا شيئا
تمضي ولا تبالي. لكن هنا واشنطن
تجد الحل لايقاف غزو الصين
لا يمكن ان تقبل تهديدات واشنطن
للرياض على خلفية قرار خفض انتاج
الاوروبي وبعد الامارات ها تركيا
تصطف بجانب السعودية. وعلى لسان
تلك الضربات يا ترى? ليعلن
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
وفق ما نقلت وسائل اعلام فرنسية
فعن اي اتفاقات يتحدث المجلس
بعدها انسحاب بلاده من المعاهدة
المؤسسة للميثاق الدولي للطاقة
هندي في نيويورك والسبب نفاذ
البرياني. وللمرة الثانية المجلس
الحوثي توقظها فهل تشتعل الحرب
مجددا في اليمن? هفوة جديدة.
بايدن يضل طريقه للنزول عن
المنصة بعد خطاب القاه في مدينة
بالعمل مع الحكومة العراقية.
فماذا يفعل العراقيون اليوم بهذه
حضرموت بينما ترد الحكومة
الشرعية خياراتنا مفتوحة للتعامل
بيان صادر عن الحوثيين هم يعلنون
تنفيذ ضربة تحذيرية. الهدف منع
في شتاء شديد البرودة. افريقيا
ستكون ملاذنا وستعوضنا عن غاز
وزير الخارجية الامريكي بلينكن
في مؤتمر صحفي ويقول ان واشنطن
بينما اعلن رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
شارل ميشيل ان قادة الدول السبع
الحقتموها بهم? الا يا هؤلاء
الاحداث والتطورات. الكشف عن
ستدرس كل وسيلة تعزز الدبلوماسية
مع روسيا لانهاء الحرب في
لدى العراق لينر رومانسكي وتؤكد
ان الولايات المتحدة ملتزمة
ان بكين نفذت كل وعودها في وقت
ابكر مما تم الاعلان عنه. الصين
العيون الضيقة في طريقهم حتى
احتار الامريكان اي طريقة هي
للرد على غزو صيني محتمل لتايوان
اعتبارا من العام الحالي. مضيفا
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
جاويش اوغلو الذي قال ان انقرة
اطلاقه من طائرة روسية باتجاه
طائرة غير مسلحة تابعة لسلاح
ضاقت بهم الارض ذرعا. فكلما
اتجهوا نحو باب يتم اغلاقه في
الامريكان والانجليز اكثروا
الظلم في العراق وثم نفوا التهمة
للناتو. فهل تكفي هذه الرسائل
لينتقل الخطر الروسي من اوكرانيا
سفينة كانت تحاول نهب النفط
الخام عبر ميناء الضبة بمحافظة
عنهم، وقالوا انهم لم يأتوا الا
من اجل اسلحة الدمار الشامل. هم.
النفط من منظمة اوبك بلس كما شدد
على ان هذا الاستقواء والتنمر من
معتبرا ان سعر برميل النفط كان
ينبغي ان يكون الان اكثر من
قواتها في لوجانسك. لكن خوف كييب
الاكبر هو ان تأتي الضربة قاصمة
البرلماني اللبناني يفشل لانتخاب
رئيس جديد للبنان. الاوروبيون
سابق ليكشفوا حقائق فاضحة عن
واشنطن ولندن. يقول فيه بريطانيا
نعم انها ضربة قوية منبعها رابع
اكبر مصدري الغاز المسال الى
مع الهجوم الحوثي على ميناء
الضبة. الهدنة نائمة وجماعة
القارة العجوز. نعم نيجيريا هنا
شركة نيجيريا للغاز المسال تعلن
التصريحات يا الينا? هل ستخرجه
من الدمار والجراح والالام التي
في بلاد الرافدين الا وجعلوه
كالرماد. عن اي قسوة نتحدث. نعم،
ذلك رسميا لن نستطيع تزويد
اوروبا بالغاز والسبب انتشار
امام بكين يا سادة? جروح العراق
القديمة تنزف. لقد عاثوا في
خطة مشتركة لانتاج اسلحة مع
تايوان. فهل يجد هذا الحل نفعا
بالصدمة التي قد تفقدهم وعيهم
وذلك اضافة الى ضربات موجعة قد
الاستخبارات الاوكرانية ان روسيا
ارسلت مزيدا من التعزيزات وتحشد
لتايوان. حيث كشف مجلس الاعمال
الامريكي عن عزم واشنطن اقامة
كوريلا غواصة نووية امريكية في
بحر العرب في رسالة ردع قوي
الامريكية ويؤكد انه يجب على
الجيش الامريكي ان يكون جاهزا
يسبق عاصفة الحرب العالمية. ومن
اعماق البحار الى بر المعارك.
الامثل لاعاقة التنين الصيني
ليأتي مدير العمليات البحرية
الفيضانات على نطاق واسع. وبجانب
الحليف الابيض هي اليوم الطبيعة
زيارة وزير الخارجية الروسي
لافريقيا قد اثمرت نتائجها.
طرف الولايات المتحدة ليس امرا
صائبا. وتوجه الى الولايات
تستهدف وقف ارتفاع اسعار الطاقة.
فما الذي يستطيعون فعله بعد كل
والعشرين الاعضاء في الاتحاد
اتفقوا على العمل على اجراءات
اوراق واشنطن. امش عدل يحتر عدوك
فيك. وبسرعة جنونية يمضي اصحاب
تعلن عن تحالفها الجديد مع
بوتين. فهل هي اعذار وهي? ام ان
روسيا. هكذا قالها الاوروبيون
الذين فطمتهم روسيا عن غازها منذ
لم تنقذاها فوجدت طوق النجاة بعد
ان كانت على شفا ازمة غاز خانقة
انهاء الحرب باوكرانيا فلما كل
هذه الاتصالات ايها الامريكان.
ايران. فهل تقبل واشنطن بهذا
الاقتراح التركي؟ الصين تحرق
المتحدة قائلا ان اردتم ان تنخفض
البترول والغاز ترفع العقوبات عن
اوكرانيا برغم ان بلينكن يقول ان
لا مؤشرات على رغبة روسيا في
مفتوحة في خط ساخن الهدف منه منع
الاشتباك كما تقول واشنطن ليخرج
بداية الحرب الاوكرانية وهم في
امس الحاجة اليه لكن الملاذ ياتي
برود للاعصاب موسكو ترد. ان ذلك
كان نتيجة عطل فني يا له من عذر
جويتين في نهاية الاسبوع الماضي
والهدف كان اعتراض طائرات روسية
الى بريطانيا. وزير الدفاع
البريطاني يصرح هناك صاروخ تم
تلقتها القارة العجوز من مناطق
اخرى. اي حال تعيس تعيشه اوروبا.
حلقت قرب حدود الناتو في بولندا
بوتين يواصل ارسال رسائله
بلاروسيا بهدف قطع امداد السلاح.
فهل يستخدم بوتين ورقة بلاروسيا
وما بين امريكا وروسيا غرقت
وتمسكت بقشة قطر والصين لكنهما
ماكر. وبين هذا وذاك اصبحت قنوات
الاتصال بين امريكا وروسيا
الجو الملكي البريطاني وذلك خلال
دورية فوق البحر الاسود. وبكل
في هذا الوقت? وليست الغواصة
الروسية فقط هي من تقترب من حدود
وحلفاؤها. هنا الاقمار الصناعية
ترصد غواصة يوم القيامة بالقرب
بتدخل بلاروسيا. فبعد تشكيل فرقة
عسكرية موحدة بين موسكو ومينسك.
دول الناتو. هنا سلاح جوي
الايطالي يعلن عن تنفيذ طلعتين
من القطب الشمالي الروسي وعلى
بعد حوالي اربعمائة وثلاثة
بين حلف الناتو وعلى رأس امريكا
لتقف في الصف الاخر روسيا
فكيف سترد لندن وبالقوة القاهرة
القشة التي قسمت ظهر الاوروبيين
في وجه الولايات المتحدة.
والاستخبارات الامريكية تحدد
غواصة يوم القيامة تظهر بالقرب
من الناتو وواشنطن تظهر برد قوي
يدك والا كسرتها يا هذا انزل.
احدث تحذير من الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين. ووفق صحيفة هنا
الدفاعات الاوكرانية ترى ان
روسيا قد تشن هجوما من حدود
وها هو ببزته السوداء. بوتين
يتفقد للمرة الاولى عناصر
لايران وروسيا بحسب مصدر في
البنتاجون. هذا هو الاحماء الذي
ياتي الرد بالمثل ولكن هذه المرة
من واشنطن حيث استقبل قائد
وخمسين كيلومتر من حدود الناتو
خطر بوتين يقترب اكثر وهذا هو
البارود في حدودها والذي يفصله
شرارة قد تسقط سهوا لتحل الكارثة
بالغاز فهل من مغيث? وبعد
الامارات تركيا تقف مع السعودية
الاحتياط قبل ارسالهم الى
اوكرانيا. بينما تقول
القيادة المركزية الامريكية في
الشرق الاوسط الجنرال ايريك
بوتين يظهر وسط قواته وامريكا
تطلب التفاوض وكييف تخاف من دخول
موعد غزو تايوان والعراق يئن من
جراح الماضي والحوثيون يشعلون
اجواء الحرب بعد انتهاء الهدنة.
اوروبا في ورطة. الايادي الراجفة
جارتها الشمالية الى الحرب.
وروسيا تتحرش عسكريا ببريطانيا.
لترسل روسيا طائراتها الى حدود
الحلف وايطاليا ترد هذه المرة.
وجوههم. فمن ينقذ القارة العجوز
من مأزق